traits now remember that is from july
all the way september
we only picked up a trace of rain in the
season we get the most
amount of rain so let's hopefully that
changes this year
94 right now centenni hills 91 in
summerlin 92 for the lakes 97 for
downtown 95
for sunrise manor 94 for green valley
and henderson 93
rhodes ranch mountains edge you're at 93
southern highlands at 95. so
last last week we had hundreds all
across the valley
only 90s this time around the only
triple digits i see
on this regional map is death valley 102
elsewhere though
90s in prompt 99 for lofland 93 in
boulder city a lot better than last week
warm yes
but not 105 to 109 thankfully
clouds coming in from the south there's
that disturbance out there spinning the
clouds towards us but notice no echoes
coming back
we could use some rain just not seeing
it here we will have a system that will
dive down along with that another
dip in the jet stream that will drop our
temperatures each day
beginning tomorrow and wait till you see
what we're forecasting for thursday
your winds will also increase as that
trough approaches so breezy tomorrow
windy on wednesday your gusts could get
up to 35 to 40
and then thursday we'll have some
leftover gusts before those winds
decrease more so
remember last friday 109 degrees we tied
the record thursday we're calling for
89 on thursday that is way below normal
almost 10 degrees below normal
breezy and cooler on thursday here's
your forecast 71 overnight partly cloudy
and it will be breezy this evening
unfortunately 94 for tomorrow
it will be breezy again and it'll be
warm but still below average 97's are
normal
neighborhood by neighbor temperatures
remember triple digits last week
91 in summerlin tomorrow centennial
hills you'll be at 92 along with
mountains edge
north las vegas 93 92 henderson green
valley 96
outside the valley yeah you'll still be
at the hundreds death valley
106 for you tomorrow pump at 91 and
boulder city 92.
here's your eight on the eight eight day
forecast here we've noted we talked
about those winds
and there's your numbers dropping all
right we'll see those numbers in 94 95
and then
89 98 friday and then right back to the
heat
just in time for the pool weekend denise
over to you
all right